bonjour à vous de l'hiver quelles sont
les dernières informations qui sont les
risques que la situation ne s'aggrave
autour d'eux apport idiot
d'abord il faut souligner que kiev nie
absolument la responsabilité de ses
frappes sur la centrale de zaporijia qui
évacue les russes de tirer sur cette
centrale et on veut pour preuve le fait
que les soldats russes et ils seraient
environ 500 sur le site savent
visiblement compter ce qu'il va y avoir
des frappes et se rendent tous aux abris
alors que les travailleurs ukrainien qui
continue de travailler à cette centrale
malgré le fait qu'elle est occupée par
la russie depuis le 4 mars ne sont pas
informés quand il va y avoir des frappes
et n'ont même pas accès au sous sol pour
se mettre à l'abri résultats il y a cinq
travailleurs ukrainien de la centrale de
zaporijia qui ont été blessés par ses
frappes ces derniers deux jours mais ce
qui inquiète encore plus que ces
blessures bien sûr c'est lady gaga les
dégâts et les dégâts potentiels infligée
au site pour le moment il semblerait que
seulement deux censeurs capteurs de
radioactivité auraient été endommagés
mais cela permet de penser qu'on ne peut
pas être sûr qu'il n'y a pas de fuites
de radioactivité en ce moment energoatom
l' agence qui gère les centrales
nucléaires en ukraine dit que la
centrale des aborigènes fonctionne
actuellement avec un risque de fuite de
radioactivité est aussi avec un haut
risque d' incendies notamment à cause de
la présence en assez grand nombre de
véhicules militaires russes sur le site
et même à l'intérieur de certains
bâtiments où sont ceux ci se situent les
réacteurs alors tout cela inquiète
beaucoup et le chef d oeuvre boîte
hommes petro cottyn appel non seulement
à ce que des inspecteurs internationaux
aient accès au site mais allons voir une
mission de soldats de maintien de la
paix et à la démilitarisation de la zone
il estime qu'il est absolument capital 1
d'essayer de persuader les soldats
russes de sortir de ce site mais il
souligne aussi que l'ukraine n'a pas
l'intention d'essayer de les faire
sortir par la force parce que bien sûr
les crânes est bien consciente de la des
dangers que cela représente intérêt
merci beaucoup gilbert craag qu'envoyé
spécial de france24 merci à vous pour
toutes ces précisions